experimentally that would mean that measurements made by Lucas would have no effect on Rihanna's particle and vice
versa this could put some limits on how correlated the two measurements can be according to Bourn though this state
sigh is all that can be said about the pair of particles prior to measurement so the measurement of one particle
affects the outcome of the measurement of the other this may have different implications for the correlations between measurements let's see how each
Theory affects these correlations in the hidden variables treatment there's a secret set of instructions prior to
measurement that already determines what Lucas will measure along each of the three axes for example these
instructions could be positive if Lucas measures along an axis a
positive if he measures along B and negative if he measures along c we can
write this as plus a plus b and minus C then Rihanna's particle
would need to have the variables minus a minus B and plus C to make sure that the total
spin along any single direction is zero
there are eight sets of possible instructions that satisfy this spin zero constraint so each time a new pair of
particles is sent to Lucas and Rihanna it could contain any one of these eight sets of instructions so now we want to
figure out assuming the particles contain one of the secret sets of instructions given in the table and
assuming that Lucas and Rihanna each independently choose which of the three axes to measure along what is the
probability that they both measure the same sign if the instructions are those given in rows 1 or
8 then clearly this probability is zero since the two particles will have the opposite signs regardless of their
measurement axes but what about the instructions in row two they would measure the same signs if
Rihanna measured along c and Lucas measured along either a or b or if Lucas
measured along c and Rihanna measured along either A or B so that's four out of nine of the
possible measurement combinations that will give Lucas and Rihanna the same sign if we do this for
each set of the instructions you'll see that Rows 3 through 7 also give a probability of 4 9ths this means that if
Einstein is right and hidden variables like these predetermine the outcome of measurements there's no way for Lucas
and Rihanna to ever measure the same sign with probability greater than 4 9th this is the Bell inequality P less than
or equal to 4 9ths and as we'll show entangled particles violate this so to
see what quantum mechanics predicts say Lucas measures long a two things can happen either he measures spin up so
Rihanna would measure spin down along a or he measures spin down and Rihanna would measure spin up along a but we
want the probability that Rihanna measures the same sign as Lucas along any axis of her choosing not just a if
she measures along either B or C it gets a little complicated it turns out that
if you know what Rihanna will measure with 100% certainty along One Direction then you can calculate the probabilities
that she will measure up or down along any other axis with a little geometry
if your state always measures spin up along one axis then the probability of measuring spin up along a different axis
will be equal to the square of the cosine of 1/2 of the angle between the two axes that's a little complicated but
I'll show you what I mean if Lucas measures spin up along a we know with 100% certainty Rihanna would measure
spin down if she were to measure a a so we can represent that with a vector VOR
like this in this case the angles between this vector and the other two measurement axes B and C are both
60° so 1 half of that is 30° and cosine of
30 is shown here cosine squar of
30° equal 34s now what if Lucas measures spin down
along a we know Rihanna would measure spin up along a so we can draw another Vector here now
this Vector representing this knowledge is 120° from each of the other two axes B
and C so we can do the same geometry trick but this time we'll get cosine of
60° so cosine squared of
60° equal 1/4 since Lucas is equally likely to
measure spin up and spin down along a we need to average these two probabilities of Rihanna we end up with a final
probability that Rihanna will measure the same sign as Lucas of 1 12 so P
equal 12 1/2 is bigger than 4 9ths so Bell's inequality is is violated
that means that as long as the rules of quantum mechanics hold hidden variables are impossible now we can use kcit and an
IBM quantum computer to test the Bella inequality with real Quantum measurements we can map the spin up and
spin down states of Lucas and Rihanna's particles to the zero and one states of the cubits in the quantum computer we'll
take two cubits one to represent Lucas's particle and one for Rihanna's and entangle them with this Quantum circuit
so the two cubits are represented by the two wires q0 and q1 and this combination
of X hadamard and c not Gates will make the same entangled State we had between Lucas and Rihanna's particles now we
need to measure each Cubit we'll set Lucas's measurement to be along a which we'll say is the Z axis then Rihanna's
measurement can be along a b or c so we'll need three separate circuits for each of these three cases but in this
video we'll just do one you can go to the module Linked In the description for the full thing if Rihanna measures along
B then our circuit looks like this where r y is a rotation of 120 de to change
Rihanna's measurement axis we can use the kcit Primitive sampler to run this experiment many times and collect
statistics from the resulting measurements the two columns 0 0 and 1 1 represent the times when Lucas and
Rihanna measured the same sign which is what we're after so the probability of measuring both particles to have the
same sign is very nearly 1/2 this violates Bell's inequality this means